وصل وفدان سعودي وعماني الى العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء واجرى الوفدان مباحثات مع
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين وكانت
المباحثات مناسبه اعرب خلالها الجانبان عن
تسمينهما لجهود احلال السلام في اليمن
وقالت ايران انها مستعده للمساعده في
تسويه الازمه اليمنيه مؤكده ان تحسن
العلاقات بين طهران والرياض سينعكس ايجابا
على دول المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حيثيات زياره
الوفدين السعودي والعماني الى صنعاء في ظل
حديث جميع الاطراف عن قرب التوصل الى
اتفاق سلام في اليمن وهل باتت الظروف
مهيئه للوصول الى اتفاق ينتهي بسلام حقيقي
بعد حرب استمرت ثمان سنوات كيف ستتم تسويه
الاوضاع الداخليه والخارجيه والملفات
العالقه في ضوء ما تسرب مؤخرا من خريطه
طريق للسلام بين الاطراف اليمنيه وما هي
انعكاسات هذه المحادثات على اطراف النزاع
والمنطقه وعلى المشهدين الاقليمي والدولي
وما مدى تاثرها بالاتفاق السعودي الايراني
[موسيقى]
هل بات النزاع في اليمن قاب خطوه من
السلام يطرح السؤال بقوه حراك اقليمي بلغ
ذروته بزياره وفدين سعودي وعماني العاصمه
صنعاء للالتقاء بالحوثيين والبحث معهم عن
سبل احلال السلام خطوه استندت فيما يبدو
لتقارب سعودي ايراني اكد الجانبان انه
سينعكس ايجابا على دول المنطقه واليمن
يتصدر القائمه وفق اول المؤشرات مسؤول
يمني وصف بالرفيع قال في تصريحات صحفيه ان
اتفاقا مع الحوثيين يمدد الهدنه الحاليه
معهم من سته اشهر الى سنه سيشمل الجوانب
الانسانيه والاقتصاديه بخطوات واجراءات
ملموسه المصدر نفسه اضاف ان تلك الاجراءات
سيعقبها حوار سياسي مباشر هدفه الاساس
التوصل لحل دائما النزاع في البلاد
المسؤول اليمني قال ايضا ان الاتفاق مع
الحوثيين يشمل توسيع الرحلات الى مطار
صنعاء الدولي كما سيتضمن الاتفاق تصديرا
النفط من الموانئ وفتح الطرقاته في محافظه
تعز كما سيتضمن ايضا اطلاقا كليا لصراح
الاسرى ونقل البضائع مباشره الى ميناء عدن
[موسيقى]
لمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من اسامه
الروحاني المدير التنفيذي لسياسات
والشراكات بمركز صنعاء لدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومعنى من مسقط الدكتور عبد
الله الغيلاني الاكاديمي والباحث في
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك
دكتور عبد الله الغيلاني ما هي حيثيات هذه
الزياره للوفدين العماني والسعودي الى
صنعاء في ظل تنامي الحديث عن امكانيه
الوصول الى تسويه سلميه للنزاع في اليمن
[موسيقى]
اليهود الى حاله الانهاك الاستراتيجي التي
اصيبت بها اطراف الصراع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تحديدا والحوثيين والجيش الوطني
فالحديث يجري عن تمديد الهدنه لمده سته
اشهر اخرى
كذلك دفع الرواتب
الموظفين وبالذات الموظفين الشماليين
القابعين تحت الخاضعين لسلطه الحوثيين
كذلك فتح المنافذ
البحريه والجويه مطار صنعاء وميناء
الحديده تحديدا تبادل الاسره وهي عمليه
كبيره جدا اذا تمت ويفترض ان تتم في شهر
ابريل الجاري فالحديث الان يجري حول انجاز
او احداث اختراق في هذا المستوى التكتيكي
بعد ذلك يمكن الشروع في التفاوض حول عمليه
احلال السلام وهذه عمليه انا في تقديري
سوف تستغرق وقتا طويلا
الحديث يجري حول مرحله انتقاليه تمتد يعني
سنتين او اكثر من سنتين ولكن الامر شائك
ومعقد وهناك جمله من التراكمات التي
تراكمت عبر يعني السنين الثمانيه المنصمه
التي كانت تشهد حربا دروسا بين التحالف من
جهه وبين يعني الحوثيين من جهه اخرى فمن
المبكره
في كل هذه النقاط التي تحدثت بها ولكن
دعنا نسال الدكتور اسامه الروحاني ضيفنا
من
رايه في المشهد الذي رايناه في صنعاء
بالامس في ظل الظروف الاقليميه المحيطه هل
برايك دكتور اسامه الظروف نضجت من اجل
الشروع في الحديث عن سلام في اليمن ام لا
انا اعتقد بان التحركات الحاليه هي
التحركات الاكثر جديه من سابقتها وخصوصا
ان الدوره التي تلعبها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اليوم يسعى بشكل او او باخر
لاحداث اختراق مباشر في
الجمود الذي حدث خلال الاعوام الماضيه
ولكن مهم جدا وانا اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم ان
هناك مازال مستوى عالي من الغموض والتعقيد
في هذه العمليه
التحركات اليوم
اتت من قبل السعوديه وليست اليوم وانما هي
مبااتره قامت بها السعوديه قبل ثلاثه اشهر
وقامت بحديث متبادل مع الحوثين تمخض عن
هذه اللقاءات بعض المطالب لكي يجب ان تبدو
عمليه السلام القادمه
والزياره لنراها اليوم هي
المجيء بالرد عن هذه المطالب وعن ما الذي
كيف يجب ان تكون العمليه او عمليه السلام
القادمه ما هي تشكيلتها كيف تبدا واين
تنتهي ولكن هذه كما نسمع التسريبات التي
صنعت هي ما زالت
تعبر فقط عن موقف المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وكذلك موافقه الحكومه او المعترف
بها دوليا مبدئيا على الخطوط العريضه لهذه
الاتفاق لم يتم الخوض في هذه التفاصيل
ولذلك لا يتوقع ان يتم
الخروج بخارطه الطريق واضحه خلال الايام
القادمه بالفعل السعوديه تسعى ان ان تخلق
نوع من الاتفاق الاولي حتى على الاقل في
نهايه هذه العشر الايام من رمضان وهذه ما
هو معروف لدى السعوديه فيما تسمى
الدبلوماسيه العشر الاواخر بشكل او باخر
تحاول ان تحقق اي نوع من الاتفاق ولكن لا
اتوقع ان يكون هذا الاتفاق اذا تم التوصل
اليه ان يخرج بتفاصيل كثيره وما زال هناك
الغموض لدى ايضا الحكومه المعترف بها
دوليا تفاصيل هذه البنود سواء في رفع
المرتبات او في فتح الموانئ والطرق بشكل
او باخر او حتى اذا تحدثنا عن خالد الطريق
ما زالت الاطراف تنظر الى هذا النوع من
الحديث من اماكن مختلفه ما زالت الحوثيون
ينظرون الى هذه الترتيبات انها الترتيبات
بناء ثقه وانها مركزه بشكل رئيسي حول
ترتيبات انسانيه لا اكثر ولكن السعوديه لا
تنظر الى ذلك من هذه الزاويه لان في ذلك
خطر كثير حول هذه العمليه وسيكون تكرار
للهددنا السابقه لا تنظر السعوديه اليوم
الى ان هذه التمهيدا للهدنه على ما اتصور
انا وانما هي تنظر الى تحقيق الى ايجاد
خارطه الطريق كامله لا نتكلم اليوم عن
تمديد الهدنه وانما الاتفاق عن خالد
الطريق تبدا
الاليات من الثقه متمخضه بالتفاهمات
الانسانيه التي تحدثنا عنها سابقا ويلي
ذلك عمليه سياسيه وانا اعتقد ان هذه خطوه
مهمه
اريد ان اسال الدكتور عبد الله الغيلاني
يعني نتحدث وتحدثت دكتور عبد الله عن
المطالب المعلنه من جانب الطرف الحوثي
الذي طالب بوقف العمليات العسكريه برفع
الحصار بتسليم اموال الرواتب وعائدات
النفط بخروج القوات الاجنبيه والتعويض
واعاده الاعمار ماذا عن المطالب مطالب
الطرف مطالب السعوديه في هذا الاطار من
اجل ولوج ما يمكن وصفه بعمليه سلام
متكامله
نعم انا في تقديري ان الرياض في هذه
المرحله تحديدا الجهود السعوديه تتمركز
حول قضيه مركزيه جدا وهي حمايه الامن
القومي السعودي
السعوديه هي الطرف الاكثر تضررا والاكثر
انهاكا من الازمه اليمنيه السعوديه قادت
هذا التحالف منذ 2015 اي منذ ان دشنت
عاصفه الحزم في مارس 2015 ومنذ ذلك الوقت
الى الان او الى قبل يعني الهدنه الاخيره
السعوديه اصيبت بحاله انهاك استراتيجيه
كبيره وبالتالي هي وصلت الى قناعه انه لا
جدوى استراتيجيه من استمرار الحرب في
اليمن فالجهود السعوديه في هذه المرحله
تتمركز حول حمايه الامن القومي السعودي
الان السؤال ما هو المدى الذي يمكن ان تصل
اليه او تريد ان تصل اليه السعوديه فيما
يتعلق بالتعاطي مع الازمه اليمنيه بمعنى
هل السعوديه سوف سوف تقف عند حد حمايه
امنها القومي وضمان ان لا تستباح اجوائها
من قبل الحوثيين وام انها سوف يعني تمضي
اكثر من ذلك وتطرح مشروع متكامل لاحلال
السلف اليمن هذا سؤال كبير جدا الحوثيون
هم الطرف الفاعل في هذه المساله هل
الحوثيون بموجب موازين القوى القائمه الان
وهم يسيطرون على شمال اليمن سيطره شبه
كامله في مقابل حكومه يمنيه معترف بها
ولكنها ضعيفه ممزقه متشضيه لم تعد تملك من
الامر شيء هل الحوثيون في ظل هذه المعطيات
على استعداد ان يقدموا تنازلات هذه
التنازلات يمكن ان تفضي الى احلال سلام
شامل بمعنى استيعاب الشركاء والفرقاء
السياسيين الاخرين انا اتصور هذا سؤال
مركزي وينبغي ان يبحث بطبيعه الحال الامر
ايضا متعلق بايران الى اي درجه يمكن
لايران ان تضغط على الحوثيين وتدفعهم الى
يعني تقديم تنازلات من شان يعني ان تنجز
خارطه طريق من خلال هذه هذه التفاوضات او
المرحله الانتقاليه خارطه الطريق تفضي في
النهايه الى اعاده انتاج يمن ديمقراطي
متماسك يستوعب كل الفرقاء بما في ذلك
المجلس الانتقالي في الجنوب
الحكومه الشرعيه طارق صالح الذي يسيطر على
الساحل الغربي وكل الفرقاء السياسيين
والقبليين في اليمن هذه مساله انا اضع
حولها علامه استفهام كبرى اذ ما الذي يمكن
ان يكره الحوثيين في هذه في هذا الظرف
الاستراتيجي وضمن هذه المعطيات القائمه ما
الذي يمكن ان يدفع الحوثيين الى تقديم
تنازلات والتنازل عن السلطه وهم يسيطرون
على شمال اليمن
الروحاني ما رايك هل يمكن ان يقدم الطرف
الحوثي على تقديم مثل هكذا تنازلات
الاستيعاب جميع المكونات
في المرحله المقبله
اذا عدنا قليلا فقط لماذا طالب الحوثين
بالفعل الخطوط العريضه لنتحدث عنها دفع
الرواتب فتح الطرق كل هذه القضايا طالبت
بها الاطراف خلال فتره الهدنه السابقه ولم
تحقق مطالب به الحوثيون في يناير عند
زياره السفير السعودي اليهم كانت عن كيفيه
عمل ذلك ويبدو ان الحوثين كانوا واضحين
جدا انهم ليسوا مستعدين ان يقوموا ان
يقوموا بتوقيع هذه الاتفاقيه مع المجلس
الرئاسي هو يمثل الطرف الاخر وانما يريدون
ان يكون هذا الاتفاق مباشره مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اذا اخذنا هذا كاحد
الامثله او احد المعطيات ان الحوثين حتى
اليوم ليسوا بالفعل مستعدين على الاقل
تصريحاتهم ان يعملوا في اطار
واحد مع بقيه الاطراف اليمنيه ما زال هذا
النوع من التفكير موجود وما زال قائم
ولذلك هذا يعود ايضا للتعليق السابق هل
يرى الحوثيين الى هذه الى هذا النوع من
الحديث لاجراء اتفاقات حول مفاهيم انسانيه
او ابعاد انسانيه فقط او تنظر اليها بشكل
كلي لا نرى اي يعني اي مؤشر حتى اللحظه ان
الاطراف مستعده للخوض في العمل في اطار
دوله واحده او حتى اذا نظرنا الى طريقه
عمل كل الطرفين لا اعتقد ان الارضيه مهيئه
حتى اللحظه وهذا ما كنا نشير اليه من
التعقيد الذي يشوب هذا النوع من الحديث
وهنا ياتي القلق هل سياتي هذا الحديث او
سيتوقف هذا الاتفاق فقط في
تحقيق الاهداف
دكتور اسامه هذا ربما يدفع ايضا الى
السؤال عن مصير المجلس الرئاسي الذي
يتراسها السيد رشاد العليمي في المرحله
المقبله في ظل الرفض الحوسي كما تفضلت وفي
ظل ضعف هذا المجلس والخلافات التي شابت
عمله في المرحله الماضيه كما ذكر لنا
الضيف من عمان ما هو مصير
هذا المجلس
هذه هي احد التحديات اذا كان الحوثيون
فعلا رافضين ان توقع الاتفاقيه مع المجلس
الرئاسي فهذه ستكون احد
التحديات امام التوصل الى اي اتفاق كان لا
يمكن للسعوديه ان تستجيب بتقبيل لمطالب
الحوثي في توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه بشكل مباشر
وندي مع الحوتين هذا يضر السعوديه واعتقد
ان السعوديه ليست بتلك السذاجه ان تخوض في
مثل هذا النوع من الاتفاق دون موافقه
الاطراف اليمنيه ولكن لا اعتقد ان
الحوثيين يعني اذا راينا تفاعلهم مع زياره
السفير السعودي وتفاعلهم ايضا حتى على
المناخ العام لا هذا النوع من المطلب بدا
ينخفض الى حد كبير ويبدو انهم سيذهبون
بهذا الاتفاق وحتى وان ذهبوا بهذا بهذا
الاتجاه وبالتوقيع مع المجلس الرئاسي
سيحقق الحوث الكثير من نجاحات في هذه
الجزئيه لانه يتحدث عن ان تدفع جميع
الرواتب على سبيل المثال من موارد النط
والغاز هذا يعني ان الحديث السابق اخرج عن
اتفاقيه بان تدفع المرتبات من عائدات
الموانئ زي ميناء الحديده وان يتشارك كل
الطرفين في دفع هذه الرواتب اليوم يتحمل
مسؤوليه كامله الحكومه المعترف بها دوليا
وسيدفع الفارق السعوديه بالتاكيد ولكن هنا
هناك بعد سياسي وهناك بعد ايضا له علاقه
بالبعد القانوني ان الاموال التي ستخرج من
مناطق الحكومه المعترف بها دوليا ستذهب
وستدفع الرواتب في مناطق الحوثين وهذا ليس
بالامر السلبي اطلاقا هو امر ايجابي ولكن
هناك مكسب سياسي للحوثي اليوم هو اعتراف
مباشر ولذلك اذا حققت هذه الاتفاقيه اتفاق
انساني فقط دون الحديث عن المرحله
السياسيه التي ستلحق هذا الاتفاق الانساني
وبذلك نرى ان الحوثي قد ينظر او جماعه
انصار الله ينظرون الى هذا التصرف بانه
احد التكتيكات لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه
واقتصاديه وانسانيه في مرحله قصيره
ومن ثم ستعود المياه الى مجالها
عن الحديث دكتور عبد الله الغيلاني الان
ايران والمسؤولون الايرانيون يقولون انهم
مستعدون للمساعده في التوصل الى تسويه
لماذا يتم التشكيك بامكانيه ان يقوموا
بالضغط على الحوثي من اجل تلبيه المطالب
وانهاء هذا الملف
نعم اولا هذا هو الخطاب التقليدي الايراني
ايران طالما تنصلت عن تورطها في الازمه
اليمنيه
فالابداء الاستعداد الايراني يعني
المساعده في احلال السلام في اليمن هو
امتداد للخطاب التقليدي ولكن انا في
تقديري ان ايران لن تضغط بدرجه كافيه على
الحوثيين بحيث تدفعهم الى تقديم تنازلات
يعني ما حدث منذ ان تم الاطاحه بالحكومه
اليمنيه حكومه الرئيس هادي والى اليوم
احدث تحولا جذريا في موازين القوى على
المستوى العسكري على المستوى السياسي على
المستوى القبلي وبالتالي في تقديري ان
الحوثيين ليسوا على استعداد لان يقدموا
تنازلات وليست ايران ايضا في هذه المرحله
على استعداد بان تدفع الحوثيين الى تقديم
تنازلات بحيث يتحول الحوثيون الى مجرد
فريق سياسي يشارك الاخرين في اداره في
اداره
تجديد اله دنه دكتور عبد الله من دون ان
ننتقل الى المرحله التي تتبع ذلك بالشروع
بمحادثات سلام وايجاد تسويه نهائيه كيف
سيكون عليه مستقبل البلاد باعتقادك
الوضع سيكون كالتالي في في تقديري اولا
حاله الانقسام والتشضي التي عليها اليمن
سوف تستمر الجنوب سوف يكون تحت سيطره
المجلس الانتقالي حضرموت والمهر سوف تبقى
يعني كما هي عليه الان شبه مستقله وان
كانت رسميا تحت مظله الحكومه الشرعيه
ولكنها عمليا هي شبه مستقله الساحل الغربي
فيه يعني شركاء متشاكسون الشمال يسيطر
عليه الحوثيون الحكومه حكومه المجلس
الانتقالي سوف تبقى مسيطره على مارب
واجزاء من تعز وبالتالي سيدخل اليمن حال
الجمود الهدنه سوف تمدد قطعا لان هذه رغبه
سعوديه حوثيه مشتركه وستمدد لسته اشهر
وليس لشهرين قابله للتمديد دفع الرواتب في
تقديري انه سوف يتم كذلك فتح المنافذ
الحديده ومطار صنعاء سوف يتم هذا الامر
عمليه تبادل الاسره سوف تتم وسيبدا الشروع
في المرحله الانتقاليه التي يمكن ان تمه
يعني احداد تحول في اليمن ولكن هذه
المرحله هنا العقده هنا الاشكال هنا
الاعضلات هذه المرحله متوقعه لها ان تستمر
سنتين ولكن في تقديري انها سوف تمتد اكثر
من ذلك وكما قلت ان الرياض في هذه المرحله
يعنيها بالدرجه الاولى وضحت فكرتك دكتور
عبد الله اريد ان استمع الى راي السيد
اسامه الروحاني اسامه الروحاني باعتقادك
لما يمهد مثل هكذا وضع
اوضحه لنا الدكتور عبد الله
انا اعتقد ان الخطوه الذي ما يجري اليوم
من محادثات هي مهمه وهي خطوه في المسار
الصحيح وان كانت بوجهه نظري لن تحقق ما
يتم الحديث عنها انها ستحقق سلام دائم او
انها ستؤسس لفتره انتقاليه لا اعتقد ان
الجميع
جاهزون خصوصا جماعه
تبقى على حالها والوضع يبقى على حاله في
البلاد مع ربما توقف للعمليات العسكريه
وحلحل في الملفات الانسانيه هذا الامر ان
حدث لما يمهد باعتقادك
انا اعتقد كما اشرت ان هذا سيخفف من
التوترات سيسمح لمناخ افضل للحديث ما بين
جماعه الحوثي وما بين جماعه انصار الله
بالتاكيد بين الحوثيين وما بين الحكومه
المعترف بها دوليا بالتاكيد الانقسام
الموجود في داخل الحكومه المعترف بها
دوليا سيستمر ما زال هناك قضايا خلافيه في
اوساط المجد الى الرئاسي حول كيفيه حتى
الحديث مع جماعه انصار الله ما زال هناك
تحفظ على بعض هذه القضايا وعلى كيفيه
مقاربتها ولذلك اذا تم المضيف فقط في
الملف الانساني لا اعتقد ان هناك سيحدث
الكثير من التغيير سواء ان الوضع سيستمر
على ما هو عليه ولن نرى اي تقدم في هذا
الملف خلال
اسامه الروحاني المدير التنفيذي لسياسات
والشراكات بمركز صنعاء لدراسات
الاستراتيجيه ومن مسقط الدكتور عبد الله
الغيلاني الاكاديمي والباحث في الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]